ما كان قبل شهر بمثابه غنائم حرب وجوائز
ملقاه في ساحه المعارك تحول اليوم لصداعا
وثقل اضافيه على عاتق الجنود الاكرانيا في
الحرب القوات الروسيه وبعد انسحابها
وخرسون تركت وراءها دبابات ونقلات جون
مدرعه وعربات مشات قتاليه لن تستطيعن
تجليها من ارض المعركه بعضها شكل اغنيمه
نادره تمثلت بدبابات بثلاثه وهي من قلائل
الاسلحه الثقيله من نوعها التي استولى
عليها الاوكرانيون هذه الدبابه مسلحه
بمدفع الرئيس من عيار 100 ملي متر ومدفع
اليه عيار 30 م لكن بعد اعاده طلاءها
وازاله حرف
z او الرمز z وتشغيلها ليسابيع بدا محركها
ونظام التزوج بالوقود في التعثر بالتالي
توقفت هذه المركبات وهذه الانواع من
المركبات القتاليه الروسيه عن العمل وعلقه
في موقع اصلاح في
ومناطق اخرى في شمالي شرق البلاد كتيبه
الصيانه لم تتمكن من العثور على اجزاء
متطابقه لها كما لا يمكن استخدام اجزاء من
مركبات اوكرانيه مماثله هذه الدبابه
وغيرها التي يصفها الاوكرانيون بدبابات
اعاره او ايجار عاليه في حظائر الطائرات
بانتظار العثور على الاجزاء اللازمه
لاصلاحها حالها حال معدات مقدمه من الغرب
والتي تسحب في حال تعطلها الى منشاه تابعه
لان انتم في هولندا او ليتوانيا كما دافع
الهوت سر التي ارسلتها المانيا لكيف بينما
يمكن للقوات الاوكرانيه في كثير من
الاحيان اصلاح معداتها الخاصه على الخطوط
الاماميه للمعارك او بالقرب منها بقطع
الغيار المتاحه
[موسيقى]